but first we do turn to once again
kenosha wisconsin where after 23 hours
now of deliberation there is still no
verdict in the trial of kyle rittenhouse
it is not clear what kind of progress
the jury is making speculation is
fruitless but last night there was a
serious development outside of the
courthouse a van transporting the jury
was aggressively tailed by a freelance
producer working for nbc news at one
point the producer ran a red light in
order to keep pace with that van after
getting pulled over for several traffic
violations he claimed that he was told
under the direction of a new york-based
msdnc producer to do this follow the
follow the van with the jurors in it
kenosha police suspect this person was
trying to photograph the jurors which of
course would be an egregious offense and
danger to the juror jurors themselves in
fact following or stalking or
intimidating anybody on a jury for any
reason is a major problem with serious
real legal ramifications msdnc they have
been banished now from the courtroom
take a look
i have instructed that no one from msnbc
news will be permitted in this building
for the duration of this trial
this is a very serious matter and i
don't know what the ultimate truth of it
is
but absolutely it would go without
much
thinking
that someone who is following a
jury bus
that is a very ex that's extremely
serious matter
and we'll be referred to the
proper authorities
now in a statement nbc news denied that
the network was attempting to photograph
the jurors nbc went on to claim that
they regret the incident well the driver
said he was told to do this but do they
really the driver directly implicated a
new york producer and their coverage of
the kyle rittenhouse trial has been
unethical at best definitely not
benefiting of actual real news
organization look at liberal joe
scarborough once claiming that
rittenhouse crossed state lines with an
ar-15 and just started shooting people
up at one point he called rittenhouse a
self-appointed militia member who
unloaded 60 rounds many lies were told
by the media mob many other msdnc
employees openly referring to kyle
rittenhouse as a white supremacist or
vigilante no evidence whatsoever joy
reid triggered by what she called kyle's
white male tears and she works at nbc
news
they also at nbc falsely reported that
rittenhouse flashed a white power hand
sign after being released on bail and
another nbc headline reads quote if
convicted he'll become a right-wing
martyr if he's freed it's a message to
others like him that prison won't be in
their future at nbc news there is no
presumption of innocence no due process
for kyle rittenhouse no rule of law no
equal justice under the law no equal
application of our laws facts
eyewitnesses their accounts video
evidence none of that matters to nbc
it's always the same thing the political
narrative is way more important and
rushing to judgment take a look
here we have a 17 year old kid under age
said he bought an ar-15 because he
thought it was cool he drove across
state had his mother driving across
state lines he appointed himself a
militia member he goes around and he
ends up unloading what 60 rounds he was
well prepared by his defense attorneys
to disrupt his image as a trigger
happy vigilante who went on a shooting
rampage when you look at the totality of
his actions what you have is a racist
biased judge who is putting his thumb on
the scale in every way he can is there
any recourse this judge
has done everything but you know offered
to adopt cal right now this feels like
those cases in the 1950s where it was in
and out in and out you know somebody
white male killed someone and they were
in and out fast and acquitted is anyone
really surprised that msdnc was caught
apparently trying to stalk a van full of
jurors they have been trying to
influence and intimidate this jury from
the beginning ultimately no matter what
msdnc says about motive and white male
tears the law in wisconsin is clear an
individual may use deadly force if he or
she quote reasonably believes that such
force is necessary to prevent imminent
death or great bodily harm to himself or
herself now based on my observation of
the evidence it is more than reasonable
to believe that kyle rittenhouse faced
imminent death or great bodily harm from
joseph rosenbaum for example after it
was rosenbaum yeah he's the one that was
convicted of molesting five kids uh
vowed to bleeping kill written house and
proceeded to chase him corner him and
lunge for his gun it was more than
reasonable to believe that kyle
rittenhouse faced imminent death or
great bodily harm when a violent group
of rioters remember they chased him as
he was running away knocked him to the
ground
were attempting at that moment to stomp
his face right into the pavement and
attempting to grab his gun and
ultimately pointed another guy pointed a
loaded gun in his face before kyle took
to self-defense this is a clear-cut case
of self-defense and again i'm not on the
jury they will ultimately make the final
decision but no matter what happens in
this case nbc news the rest of the mob
in the media they all should be ashamed
of themselves
and every year somehow their credibility
gets worse and worse and worse they've
been wrong on every single solitary case
the same people that lied for three long
years about trump russia collusion the
dirty russian disinformation dossier
that hillary clinton paid for they
didn't care at all about lying to a fisa
court when it says uh affirmed affidavit
uh it never was because of course
nothing was verifiable says at the top
of a fisa application verified no it's
not verified it's been debunked and they
won't admit to the error and the lies
and the conspiracy theories and the hoax
they perpetrated on you the american
people by the way they got it wrong on
nicolas sandman they got it wrong on
ferguson missouri they got it wrong with
freddie gray uh in baltimore they got it
wrong with the cambridge police they get
it wrong with uva they get it wrong with
duke lacrosse they always get it wrong
because they always rush to judgment and
they have no evidence no facts and they
allow for no due process hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else